[Musik]
hey was geht ab jetzt willkommen beim
ein video
ja es ist gerade ich weiß gar nicht
warum ich euch sage aber es ist gerade
heidfeld und ich hab richtig doch gerade
dieses video zu drehen
das war allein auf jeden fall gut ich
hab grad fast verzweifelt weil ich kam
irgendwie auf diesem video de ich hab
fast verzweifelt ich bin auf jeden fall
gerade fast verzweifelt ich war am 14
wie sagt man das denn ich war am
verzweifeln weil ich verzweifelt war
weil ich irgendwie auf jeden fall ich
kam einfach so auf die idee sucht doch
einfach mal so mädchen trends raus die
viele jungs übels hatten das ist jetzt
natürlich mal wieder ziemlich hart
gesagt und ich wette die ein oder
anderen kommt um die ecke
dass sie vorsichtig aber leute wartet
bitte erst beim bisschen ab danke schön
alles war in der hinsicht wirklich
schwer das sich eigentlich kaum was
gefunden habt weil die meisten kennt die
vier jungs ein ziemlich geil attraktiv
wisst ihr ich habe dennoch jetzt zehn
mädchen trends rausgesucht die ihm fehle
jost in freier stellen da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher die welt einfach
vorstellen
ich will mit diesem video absolut
niemanden angreifen oder du aber ich bin
auch der festen überzeugung dass ihr
selber drüber lachen können als kleiner
trost an die mädchen
lasst euch bitte in den kommentaren so
richtig darüber aus was jungs denn für
komische trends haben die einfach über
alles hasst das wird dich interessieren
und wenn ihr bock habt dass ich einfach
mal wieder darüber machen so mädchen
trends jungs richtig cool finden oder
lieben oder gelb in oder voll drauf
abfahren
lasst einfach mal daumen nach oben daran
sehe ich das natürlich alle entwerten
ich werde gleich lange lagern gefangen
hat man und ja ok trend nummer 1 und
zwar das ist auch wirklich schon
ziemlich lange im trend das ist wirklich
mehr so auf mädchen bezogen ist lädt
aussieht ich bei mädchen auf netze
relation friedrich wirklich selbst ins
netz
deswegen steckt natürlich auch mal
selbst ja das netz hat alex w beide ab
jetzt einfach wird eingewendet und war
diese mädchen die irgendein lied nie
okay es ist wegen ein gutes lied aber
dann machen die folgendes ich zeige euch
einfach mal kurz vergehen
und wenn man dabei aus wie sie auf
deinem größte film und man ein bisschen
vom kopf sieht denkt man sich als junger
natürlich natürlich es gibt jungs sie
denkt ich brauche eigentlich habe ich
sofort an
aber er ganz ehrlich ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ihr als mädchen so was
wollt das dann halt solche jungs
ankommen und als zweites kann ich mich
auch noch sagen aber ich kann euch
anders zu sagen wenn ich mit freunden
sein video sehe macht mich halt
irgendwie drüber lustig weil
offensichtlich nutzer kann und ich sage
mir fällt da führt auch keine ausrede
ein und klagten die jetzt ankommen sagen
ach das volk sexistisch minister selbst
verstehen kann ich nicht verstehen ich
mein macht doch einfach ein cooles bild
oder so das polarisiert vielleicht nicht
ganz so aber wenn ihr bisschen sales
werden weil dann macht einfach irgendwas
anderes macht coole videos macht coole
youtube-videos oder sonst was macht
meint wegen irgendwelchen wo er nicht
eure tipps
ich hoffe wird man erschwert irgendwann
da auch wenn bestimmt viel in amerika
mit sowas berühmt geworden sind
ihr habt dann aber halten fanbase von
irgendwelchen notgeilen 14 jährigen
kindern motto the world zum nächsten
trend ich würde jetzt jetzt einfach mal
als trend bezeichnen und zwar erstens
auch aufgefallen ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
das nur bei meiner freundin der fall ist
falls ja dann bin ich wohl ein
ziemlicher nutzer allein aber ich weiß
auch von vielen anderen mädchen und
verschmähte manchmal ja danke für die
vielen herzen - schickt aber wenn ich
dann mal so den verlauf mit ihrer besten
freundin der denk mir so danke du
schickst die alte mär härter als mir die
solchen das sitze aufnehmen und ich weiß
natürlich dass machen eigentlich alle
mädchen so ihr meist auch gar nicht will
oder so aber es macht uns schon traurig
da dann spreche ich garantiert nicht für
mich alleine
er kommt zum nächsten punkt im ich hatte
wirklich überlegt ob ich das mit drei
nehme aber ich habe mir gedacht ich habe
viele jüngere zuschauer die sich
vielleicht ab und zu mal gedanken machen
wenn ich irgendwas da gelassen ich blöd
finde und die das dann halt nicht mehr
tragen oder nicht mehr durchführen oder
sonst hast keine ahnung über in dieser
sache kann
ich sagen dass es hier mehr so weit ja +
20 jährigen geld frauen aufgefallen und
deswegen nämlich für drei und war ab und
zu meinem zug ich gehe durch den zug
noch mehr platz
ich war ja ziemlich viel zug und dann
nicht manchmal frauen wo ich mir denke
so was ist das denn so weil die hat dann
einfach nicht so schminke ich weiß ich
so da geht einfach hier droht vom auge
außen schlicht noch so weiter und der
dreht sich dann so manchmal hier so und
das hat mich dann folge an so ne fliege
es kann natürlich auch sein dass ich das
in drei jahre so total attraktiv findet
aber gerade denke ich mir immer so dabei
der mann steckte ganz kurz einmal zurück
und das ist ja auch so sagt man in die
trends gekommen dass sich viele frauen
hier sowas hin malen oder importeurs
oder wir machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten fünf jahre englisch und doch
viel eingefallen und ich habe dann
einfach mal in der gruppe und viele
freunde von mir drinnen sind
reingeschickt leute weiter was habe ich
geschrieben was ist das in deutsch sagt
man wenn euch was einfällt du mädchen
trennt die ihr euch auch die eier gehen
dann habe ich kurz abgewartet ich weiß
nicht warum ich nicht selber sorgte
kommen aber dann kamen dieses bild ich
würde sagen das ist der krasseste trends
2016 habe ich wäre oft gesehen mir geht
es mittlerweile so auf die eier wenn ich
dich denn geboren
da kommt jetzt ein cooler snap gucke ich
drauf man versteht die hälfte mich ich
mein versteht einfach hier ist okay an
die girls da draußen alle fühlen
ich hab nichts gegen denn am schlimmsten
sind die jungen kommen und diesen filter
benutzen klein macht sich weiter mit dem
filter an sich ist natürlich auch hört
auf damit machst dich weiter mir
scheißegal alter und ich musste gar
nicht lange abwarten
da kann das nicht will und zwar dieses
hier
55 aber wie sich wetter dieser dialog
auch von diesen drei mädchen wendy einer
auf die idee kommt so ein foto zu machen
herr mädels lasst uns doch mal und
geiles neues in stepic machen wie werden
wir einfach alle drei in die h&m kabine
da drüben gehen da ist ein geiler
spiegel online heute bleiben wenig ganz
normal stehen wir knien uns erst mal hin
zeigen unsere neuen sneaker und strecken
unsere nasr aus meiner meinung nach ist
wieder komplett die gleiche situation
wie bei privat es gibt jungs die findet
schreiben viel asma treffen da geht was
und es gibt viele jungs die einfach nur
denken kommt es zum nächsten trend da
bin ich sagen ich will das mal so
einschätzen der weiß nicht nur 2016
sondern hat auch irgendwie schon seit
dem die menschheit existiert würde ich
mal schätzen aber was ich sagen kann er
wird eindeutig verstärkt jetzt durch
irgendwelche tv schuld oder meinetwegen
auch youtuber ja ich habe ja auch weil
dieses video gemacht macht mädchen nicht
tragen und meine ersten video und dann
wieder habe ich damals total falsch
eingeschätzt ich könnte mit meiner
reichweite daher noch nicht so krass gut
umgehen wie heute zeigen kann ich weiß
was ich sagen kann und ich weiß dass ich
nicht sagen kann ihr seid alles kleine
mixa wollte mal loswerden war natürlich
nur ein spaß
auf jeden fall ja durch solche videos
halt einfach leute die nicht wissen was
sie da erzählen oder was sie damit
anrichten wer dieser trend verstärkt
genau dass ich da und zwar meist damit
dieses so wenn man wirklich normale
figur hat und anderer und sagt ich will
noch dünner werden klar ist kann
natürlich auch eine kleine also da will
ich jetzt überhaupt nichts gegen sagen
aber wenn man jetzt nicht krank ist oder
sonst irgendwas und ständig zu deinem
freund oder zu freunden die ich mir noch
dünner werden ich will so und so aus wie
ich habe wieder ab genau ich habe wieder
zugenommen
ich muss jetzt wieder drei tage nicht
mehr das und das essen oder sonstwas es
doch einfach was ihr wollt manier sieht
ganz normal aus wie jedes andere mädchen
und durch irgendwelche seite dieses
germany's next topmodel oder später
wieder irgendwann strich was wirklich
kein junger verstehen kann als vorbild
genommen und dann muss man sich
andauernd anhören
ich bin so dick nein seid ihr nicht
einfach so wir wollten etwas sie wollen
und wenn ich wirklich meint du ja wenn
ich ein bisschen zu dick dann geht er
halt mal joggen oder sonst was aber
mister und doch scheißegal ob jetzt bin
ich gespannt wie der nächste punkt
ankommen das kann natürlich auch wieder
ein bisschen von oberflächlichkeit
glänzen oder sonst was aber dass wenn
wieder kommt das sind einfach mal mit
rein ich persönlich knebel auch ab und
zu mal ganz gerne meinen fingernägeln
und musste deshalb nicht nein hab ich
jetzt einfach mal gesagt nein spaß also
manchmal scheine ich ihn natürlich schon
noch selber aber ihr kennt das man
schnippelt ab und zu mal gerne daran
aber es gibt dann auch so wie celik die
denken also abkommen ich kaufen einfach
die fingernägel kann man natürlich auch
machen durch meine ich update nicht
gegen die fülle ich dann halt nur ein
bisschen unnatürlich ein bisschen
plötzlich mäßig aber es gibt dann ja
auch welche die kaufen sich welche so
lang und dann hat man so lange fällige
das weiß ich auch 2016 ziemlich im job
oft gesehen und ich habe mir immer nur
gedacht du jetzt meine freundin wenn ihr
händchen halten würden ich musste
aufpassen dass ich mich nicht schneidet
oder nicht ja er nimmt das bitte
wirklich nicht zu hart also macht durch
wie wir weil keine ahnung ich mir auch
dinge die die menschheit nicht versteht
zum beispiel keine ahnung ich bin
ehrlich mir fällt grad überhaupt nicht
mehr ein ja ist ja eigentlich was gut
ist oder also leute wenn ihr bock habt
auf den zweiten part davon einfach durch
zehn mädchen trennt die jungs lieben
oder zehn millionen trennt die mädchen
schreibt es einfach keine kommentare
interessiert mich wirklich sehr dass man
auch nach oben da also kommentar und
doch nach oben ballert das video
natürlich heftig in meine keine ahnung
wohin schaut auf jeden fall bei snapshot
und instagram vorbei ist und wir sehen
uns dann am dienstag wieder um 15 uhr
dienstag und 15
ein neues video ausprobieren ob das bei
euch besser ankommt wenn ich einfach mal
er applaudierte lange zeitreihen ich
wünsche euch noch ein angenehm tag